and challenging for you guys especially
with their defense how did you overcome
it that's a good team over there yeah I
mean you know how deep the West is so a
lot of credit goes to them and how hard
they fight and they well coach and
that's a tough team we knew they were we
knew they weren't gonna go away easy
this entire series after a season filled
with lots of talk about James Harden and
his historic numbers it took everybody
in this playoff series what do you think
about the depth and the contributions as
a whole that's how it is in the playoffs
man it's totally different from the
regular season and by the time you get
to Game five everybody knows what
everybody's got no-touch top of my head
how about this guide the free throw line
how about his free throws and I was big
man you know Chuck you know he missed
those two we could have went down that
end I've been thinking about it but
that's it's a big-ass play man to come
down there and get another steal and go
back to the line and make two big free
throws and it just shows you know that's
who he is that's what his career has
been like you know it's nice for him to
get the